[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
2016 is ending very soon but before we
all take a break to give each other
presents and drink in the new year with
age-appropriate beverages we've got one
more set of video games for you
let's get to it before we dig into the
new stuff there's a dino sized release
from last week you might have missed Ark
survival evolved is out now on ps4 and
picking it up on console gets you the
survivors pack which adds the scorched
earth expansion and its new areas and
dragons for free add that to the game's
open world survival gameplay and you
have yourself a real challenge if you're
looking to build fires craft weapons and
battle all sorts of prehistoric beasts
you can get started right now now onto
this week's releases and everyone's
favorite plumber is leading the charge
Super Mario run combines classic
platforming with Auto running sending
Mario dashing through all sorts of
fields and tunnels and castles on top of
completing courses you can also race
other players ghosts for the best time
or decorate your own Mushroom Kingdom
you can try out all three of those modes
for free on any device that runs iOS 8
or higher otherwise you can get
unlimited access for 10 bucks when the
game launches on December 15th wild guns
combined Wild West and robots back on
the Super Nintendo and now the sequel
called reloaded is doing it again this
shooting gallery adds two new characters
to the lineup so you can play the whole
thing in four player co-op some classic
stages and bosses return but you'll see
plenty of new sights along the way and
the faster you take them down the better
you'll rank in the new leaderboards you
can draw your weapon on ps4 on the 13th
[Music]
drive drive drive isn't just something
you yell at a bad driver
the name perfectly describes the game
see you're not just racing down one
track but several at the same time
you'll have to jump across multiple
tracks to deal with any drivers giving
you trouble
and the
stretch across different planets with
totally different rules of gravity and
if that's not chaotic enough for you you
can crank things up in the games track
editor you can start your engines on the
13th
now let's slow things down a bit with
stardew valley calling it an indie
Harvest Moon is a disservice because
this farming simulator also tacks on
fishing cooking crafting and romance
options you can even explore
procedurally generated mines to find all
sorts of gems and minerals stardew
valley was already a hit on pc earlier
this year and now it's making its way to
consoles you can take up your farming
tools on ps4 on the 13th and on Xbox one
on the 14th and those are the games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change but that's gonna do it for this
episode of new releases and for the year
thanks for tuning in guys and I'll be
back with more in 2017
[Music]